why do you choose to say baby instead of
fetus because it's plain language and so
I I generally try not to use sort of
Latin or jargony terms for things that
are plainly understood and so that's why
I prefer good Saxon words and good plain
words and I don't use a 25 cent word
when I can use a nickel word and as you
just said to the the guidance to um use
one word or the other based on whether
the mother wants to have an abortion or
wants to give birth to her child clearly
though you don't don't seem willing to
admit it but clearly is because the word
fetus allows this pregnant mother in
distress to abstract away the humanity
of her child whereas if she were to call
it a baby it would be much much harder
for her to justify killing the baby in
the womb through abortion right that's I
think you would acknowledge that yeah I
can acknowledge that calling it a baby
minimizes the options that the pregnant
person feels like they have and it can
put unwanted pressure onto them